MALE SPEAKER: So we're very
pleased to have the "Robot
Chicken" show leads from Stoopid
Buddy Stoodios here
today with us.
We have show creators Seth
Green and Matt Senreich.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: And we've also
got director Zeb Wells.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER:--head
writer Tom Root.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: And executive
producer.
So quick introduction.
In its six seasons on air,
"Robot Chicken" has racked up
a number of really impressive
accomplishments.
They've shown us that through
fart jokes and montages of
shots to the crotch
you can win Emmys.
Not just one, but four Emmys.
They've also clearly cornered
the market on stop motion
animation sketch comedy.
So name an '80s cartoon or a pop
culture icon, and they've
spoofed it.
And most importantly, they've
made it cool to be a nerd,
validating many childhoods in
this room spent on the floor
lying in front of the TV
on Saturday mornings.
Let's give a big round of
applause for the "Robot
Chicken" guys.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT SENREICH: Normally
we kind of open this
stuff up for questions.
We're awkward people.
SETH GREEN: We're not much for
keynote speaking, but we are
really good at in-context
conversation, so maybe--
MATT SENREICH: If you guys
have questions--
SETH GREEN: --if anybody wants
to come up to that microphone
and ask us something, it will
start us off on a 45-minute
rant about nothing.
MATT SENREICH: We're
good at those.
AUDIENCE: How did you guys
start with this stuff?
MATT SENREICH: How did we
AUDIENCE: Where did it begin?
MATT SENREICH: Tom and I used
to work at a magazine called
"Wizard" and "ToyFare" magazine
back in the day.
SETH GREEN: For those who don't
know, "Wizard" was the
premiere genre media pre the
internet when all you could do
was wait for a magazine to
be published to give you
information about pop culture
and current events.
MATT SENREICH: So we were over
there, and one day, being an
idiot, I'd read in another
magazine that Seth was a big
toy geek and that he customized
toys of his "Buffy"
cast members as a Christmas
present.
And I was like, that would
make a great article.
SETH GREEN: I didn't think there
was any way I was going
to be on that show for several
years, and I thought I might
as well blow it out on a great
Christmas gift this year and
then never see any of these
people ever again.
I'm just kidding, obviously.
MATT SENREICH: So I ended up
reaching out to his publicist,
and we ended up just talking.
SETH GREEN: I was a huge fan
of the magazine and had
actually bought every episode
of "ToyFare" from the time
that it was invented.
So when I heard that the editor
of "ToyFare" wanted to
talk to me I was like, do you
think they'll give me a
subscription?
TOM ROOT: Is it true that
you almost didn't
get to talk to Seth?
SETH GREEN: My publicist is
an excellent gateway.
I think she asked what your
distribution was.
MATT SENREICH: Yes, she did.
SETH GREEN: And she was
unimpressed by the
circulation.
MATT SENREICH: Yeah,
we weren't "Vanity
"Fair" at the time.
SETH GREEN: Well, and
also, at the time--
I don't remember what
I was working on.
That was like '98, right?
MATT SENREICH: It was like
"Austin Powers" and "Buffy"
were happening.
SETH GREEN: It was that whole
chunk of time where lots of
good things were happening, and
she was really keeping the
gate closed.
MATT SENREICH: But you called
me back within 5 minutes.
We ended up becoming friends.
And then as that stuff
was happening--
when I was out in LA
we would hang out.
Every time he was in New
York, we'd hang out.
SETH GREEN: In advance of
Comic-Con becoming this
massive commercial event, it
was just a place that nerds
got together and talked
nerdy to each other.
So Matt and I met at Comic-Con
for several years, too.
MATT SENREICH: And it just
spiraled into just the
friendship, where one day he was
like, hey, I've got to go
on "Conan O'Brien." I have
nothing to talk about.
I was thinking maybe we'd make
a little animated short of my
action figure and maybe--
Conan O'Brien has an action
figure, I think, from just his
show, just being silly.
SETH GREEN: I'd always been
really interested in both toys
and stop motion.
And I'd heard that as a
publicity thing, Hasbro had
produced a 12-inch GI Joe-sized
Conan O'Brien toy
they'd featured on the
show and whatnot.
And I was getting a toy from
"Austin" "Powers" and thought
it would be funny if our two
dolls fought or something.
MATT SENREICH: So I enlisted
Tom, and we
put something together.
And literally, it was one of
these things where we had no
idea what we were doing.
But as we were trying to figure
out how to shoot this
little short, Sony Digital
approached us.
Before the internet was the
internet, it was all dial-up.
And said, hey, we hear you're
looking to create content.
We're looking for content for
the internet and maybe do like
4-minute shorts, maybe order
like 6 to 12 of these things.
SETH GREEN: Sony was trying to
develop a portal destination
pre-YouTube.
They wanted linear content
in an a la carte--
who could imagine that that
would work, right?
But it was pre-broadband.
MATT SENREICH: Yeah,
this was 2000.
SETH GREEN: So you're trying to
watch like 720-comparable
content over a phone line.
It was just insane.
TOM ROOT: It's also wasn't
Mac compatible.
So we turned in 12 of these
episodes, and then none of us
at work could watch
them online.
SETH GREEN: No one
on the planet
could watch them, really.
But what we wound
up with was 45
minutes of produced content.
So after the Sony platform
failed, we made a deal with
Sony Digital to shop that
content around.
You just have to remember
the time when this was.
It was between 2002 and
2004, and Adult
Swim was just forming.
They didn't really have
any original content.
"Aqua Teen," I think, was on.
And it was right when "Family
Guy" had gone off the air.
MATT SENREICH: It
was cancelled.
They just started re-airing
the stuff on Adult Swim.
Fox hadn't picked it up yet.
And Seth MacFarlane--
SETH GREEN: They hadn't put
out the DVDs or anything.
Adult Swim had just gotten the
right to re-air the old
episodes of "Family Guy." And
they got such high ratings
that it prompted Fox to
release it on DVD.
But before that even happened,
MacFarlane said you should
meet these guys at Adult Swim.
MATT SENREICH: And at the same
time, we'd already pitched
Cartoon Network, who said
it was too old.
And a guy named Sam Register
there passed it along to Adult
Swim at the same time.
So I think those two
intersecting moments happening
kind of made Adult Swim
take a look at us.
And next thing we know,
we had a show.
SETH GREEN: It really what
that matter of fact.
Matt and I had--
we all had been producing
these web shorts.
But we had five animators,
and our crew was
about 12 people total.
And then they were
like, all right.
So we want you to produce 20
quarter-hour episodes.
And Matt and I were like,
I don't know how
the hell we do that.
So we had to figure that
out in a hurry.
TOM ROOT: I'm just struck by how
many years it took to get
this show on the air.
And then the second show we did
for Adult Swim, we drew
some pictures on a dry erase
board and said we think this
could be show.
Do you want this?
And they're, like, sure,
we'll order 12 of them.
SETH GREEN: They learned
from that.
They'll never do that again.
TOM ROOT: No, that was
their mistake.
But man, when you're on the
outside of those castle walls,
it is hard.
It's hard to get in there.
SETH GREEN: We shopped
it everywhere.
Matt and I took it to everywhere
from "Comedy
Central" to "Saturday Night
Live" to "MADtv" to--
where else did we go?
We literally went--
MATT SENREICH: Went
everywhere.
SETH GREEN: We had so many names
and so many people over
those four years.
MATT SENREICH: It's
all a blur.
SETH GREEN: And just waited
for the industry itself to
change, just waited for the
outlets to become available.
Right place, right time.
MATT SENREICH: I like that
people have to get up to go to
the microphone.
We're not used to that.
AUDIENCE: But you have to sit
there with microphones.
SETH GREEN: The Tony
Robbins format.
AUDIENCE: So you have a
15-minute show in a world
where we don't have 15-minute
shows on the
internet, which is great.
Well, I mean, on the internet
you do, but on television
that's great.
Has there ever been talk
about going more?
Is it hard to fill that
15 minutes sometimes?
MATT SENREICH: It is.
TOM ROOT: I'll say in the
beginning, we were like, man,
if we do a really good job,
maybe someday this will be
half an hour.
And now our fear is that
it goes to 30 minutes.
We exhaust ourselves and the
audience, I think, in that
quarter hour.
SETH GREEN: We've had some
success producing isolated
specials that are 22-minute,
30-minute format.
But for the regular show,
there's a pace to it.
There's a way that over these
several seasons we've found it
works best.
MATT SENREICH: Yeah.
Very early on, the head of Adult
Swim, Mike Lazzo, our
long sketches, as he said,
played long, and our short
sketches played too short.
He said, so take your
minute sketches
and make them shorter.
Take your 3-second sketches
and make them longer and
you'll find your sweet spot.
So now we find like the
30-second to 2-minute stuff
works the best.
And if you lump them all
together, it's really just
sketch comedy.
It's "SNL" instead of
an hour, hour and a
half into 11 minutes.
SETH GREEN: But we take extra
care every episode.
I mean, the whole thing is
written sketch by sketch.
And then those sketches are
organized, and rough timings
are estimated.
And then we put all those on
cards and put a big jigsaw
puzzle together of what each
episode will consist of.
And then within each episode,
we rearrange those cards to
figure out what the shape
of each individual
episode will be.
And then once you shoot it or
cut it, all that changes once
you get the dialogue tracks.
We wind up cutting half the
sketches from every animatic
just because it's too much time,
not as funny, doesn't
play, complication
of production,
any number of things.
So wait, just to finish that,
no, we don't want to make the
regular show a half an hour.
It's exhausting.
Every episode takes several
weeks to accomplish.
And it's so much manpower.
It's-- no.
AUDIENCE: So my question is how
many writers do you guys
have and how your writing
process looks like?
MATT SENREICH: As far as
writing goes, Tom could
probably talk about it more.
We structure it--
Tom's one of our head writers.
I'll let you--
TOM ROOT: We've got a pair of
head writers and then some
recurring writers, like two or
three recurring writers.
MATT SENREICH: Zeb.
TOM ROOT: And then--
Zeb is one.
And then we bring in like
a rotating crew
that come in and out.
SETH GREEN: But it's broken
down into sections.
We had 20 episodes
to accomplish.
We'll break it down into
either four-week
or five-week cycles.
And then we'll have our stable
writers that are on the whole
time throughout the year.
And then we'll have other people
come in for each of
those four and five weeks.
TOM ROOT: We do 20 episodes
in 20 weeks.
And it's three weeks
of brainstorming,
then a week of scripting.
And in the scripting week, we
also start culling the herd
and murdering our children.
ZEB WELLS: And each
other's children.
TOM ROOT: Yes, well, especially
each other's children.
SETH GREEN: It's so much easier
to drown your baby.
TOM ROOT: And it's
pretty frenetic.
A lot of what makes it to
the air is pretty dumb.
And as an outsider, I would
say, oh, that looks pretty
easy to write.
But it's the quantity of dumb
stuff that we have to write.
ZEB WELLS: Finding that
right kind of dumb.
TOM ROOT: There's a specific
brand of dumb.
SETH GREEN: And it also-- it
has to come to a vote.
Like we all have to agree, or
at least have a majority
agree, that a particular sketch
or particular idea is
good enough to go
into the show.
MATT SENREICH: I think that's
the biggest thing.
The one thing that's remained
consistent is we don't write
it for other people, as
weird as that sounds.
SETH GREEN: As arrogant
as that sounds.
MATT SENREICH: We write it
to make each other laugh.
We're a group of friends that
started this show, if you
count 2013 plus years ago.
And it's just to make that
same group of people just
laugh amongst ourselves.
And if that's the case, we're
just hoping people are
laughing with us, which is our
success or failure with that.
SETH GREEN: That was the most
comforting thing about our
first season, is that we wrote
this show, this idea based on
all the things that we love
desperately and deeply that
are almost too nerdy
to say out loud.
And within our first year,
we were met with a really
encouraging response from the
collective saying, hey, I feel
the same way.
That commercial totally
fucked me up.
So there was a nice realization
that we were at
least sharing a sense of humor
culturally, and that
encouraged us to go forward.
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoy the show.
SETH GREEN: Oh, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about what goes too
far that you just
can't put it in?
What sketches you're like, OK,
we've got to hold this one.
MATT SENREICH: We've only had
a few of those, actually.
Not as many as you'd think.
SETH GREEN: And not for the
reasons that you'd expect.
MATT SENREICH: Yeah, we had one
this last season that was
a street fighter, no "Mortal
Kombat" sketch.
And it was a--
[LAUGHTER]
SETH GREEN: Right.
MATT SENREICH: It was Johnny
Cage fighting Kano.
That was that, right?
SETH GREEN: No, no, no.
It's the PTS.
It's the guy coming
home from--
he's sitting with the therapist,
and he's like, the
voice in your head isn't real.
And he's like, I just--
I just don't want it to tell
me to kill anymore.
MATT SENREICH: Because he
kept hearing, kill him.
SETH GREEN: He finally goes
home to his wife and his
family, and they're so
happy to see him.
And they're like, thank
God, you're cured.
And he's like, oh, my family.
And then he hears in his
head [DEEP VOICE]
finish her.
And he's like, ah!
MATT SENREICH: It was one of
those things where no one
caught it on the page--
SETH GREEN: But when you really
think about it, the
child cowering in the corner
saying, "Daddy no." And him
going, [YELLING].
[DEEP VOICE]
Finish them.
And then we made a silly.
Like there's a piece of pizza,
a pizza box, and after he's
punched his wife through
the chest.
And then you see the pizza box
and he goes, [DEEP VOICE]
finish it.
And he flips the box
and eats the pizza.
Ahh!
But when it went through--
MATT SENREICH: When you saw it
in animation and when SNP saw
it they, were like,
you can't do this.
SETH GREEN: We don't like this
image of a mentally disturbed
person murdering their family
and themselves.
And we were like, I guess I
hadn't thought about that.
But you see in the video game,
he's got this voice in his
head, and so--
yeah, that got cut.
TOM ROOT: It's rare, though.
They give us pretty--
a long leash.
ZEB WELLS: We cut stuff
in the room.
Sometimes it just goes farther
than we want to go.
MATT SENREICH: Such as?
ZEB WELLS: Uh--
MATT SENREICH: Yeah.
I'm trying to like
of a specific.
It's tough.
Yeah, it's not as often
as you'd think.
SETH GREEN: What was the one?
It's always like personal.
And I guess as we've all become
parents and things like
that, it changes the perspective
a little bit
because there was that-- what
was the first person shooter
in the Lamaze class?
MATT SENREICH: Oh yeah.
ZEB WELLS: That aired.
TOM ROOT: Which "Call
of Duty" was that?
ZEB WELLS: 4.
SETH GREEN: What was the game?
MATT SENREICH: "Modern
Warfare."
SETH GREEN: So we have this
very silly sketch.
TOM ROOT: Well, it's not
completely random.
SETH GREEN: No, it was based
on an actual thing.
TOM ROOT: On the airport scene
from "Modern Warfare 2."
SETH GREEN: First person
shooter game, horrific.
You play an undercover officer
that has to go into an airport
and participate in a
random murder plot
with a bunch of civilians.
And to not blow your cover, you
have to kill civilians.
That's weird in a video
game, right?
TOM ROOT: And we were
like, what's next?
How are we going to top that?
SETH GREEN: What could
the next version be?
So we had a guy kicking down
the door of a Lamaze class
and, like, murdering a bunch of
expectant mothers, and then
saying, it's OK,
I'm undercover.
[MACHINE GUN SOUND]
TOM ROOT: And that wasn't
even a network thing.
That was sort of us in the room
sort of feeling a chill
in the air.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM ROOT: One of the
rare instances we
showed a little restraint.
SETH GREEN: What was
the other time?
We never animated the stillborn
baby puppet.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM ROOT: It's always babies.
SETH GREEN: It's
always babies.
We were doing a sketch,
America's
Most Tragic Home Videos.
TOM ROOT: It's in the
delivery room.
SETH GREEN: The baby is like--
they're like one more push.
And the mother's like
[SCREAMING].
And the doctor's
like, it's a--
uh.
Uh.
[BABY CRYING]
Horrible, horrible.
MATT SENREICH: Awful.
SETH GREEN: You know it's a
very tragic home video.
TOM ROOT: I prefer we don't
share that one anymore.
It never gets a big rousing--
SETH GREEN: No one's ever like,
ah, that should have
been in the show.
They don't even applaud our
ethics for cutting it.
TOM ROOT: It just makes
them think less of us.
ZEB WELLS: Let's cleanse
our palette here.
AUDIENCE: I know you guys get
a lot of big names to do the
voices for the show.
So do you usually write with
like getting people to voice
certain characters?
Or do they say, like, oh, we
want to be on the show, and
then you kind of make
a sketch around it?
SETH GREEN: We just write.
MATT SENREICH: It's one of those
things where our first
season, we called out a lot of
favors, people that Seth has
known, and we got really
lucky really early on.
I really go back to--
I think it was like--
it was Burt Reynolds
and Don DeLuise,
Ryan Seacrest, actually--
SETH GREEN: It was, like,
going into the second--
MATT SENREICH: In like our first
five or six episodes.
SETH GREEN: season of "Idol,"
we got Seacrest to come on.
MATT SENREICH: Charlize
Theron.
It was like we had a few
big names at the
time who just like--
then when we went out to other
people, they were like, oh,
they did the show?
Well, then these people
will do it.
SETH GREEN: Once the show
existed and we didn't have to
clumsily explain the concept of
an animated sketch comedy
show starring action figures
to A-list agents, it was a
little bit better.
We could send it, and be like,
oh, Charlize Theron did this.
I'm just saying.
MATT SENREICH: And now it's got
to a place where people
come to us.
And ultimately, when we hear
someone wants to do the show,
they go on this big sheet that
we have of people who want to
do the show.
And then once we have the
scripts written--
SETH GREEN: Sometimes
it happens quicker.
Sometimes it's like, oh,
that's a perfect
part for that person.
Sometimes it's like, oh, we
can cast that person.
Or we had an idea that--
there will always be that random
like, oh, we wrote a
sketch about 50 Cent.
Let's see if he'll do it.
That kind of thing.
He did, by the way,
which was awesome.
Coolest thing ever.
MATT SENREICH: In the episode
you watched, it was like Jon
Stewart had mentioned he wanted
to be on the show.
So that was a perfect example
of we put him on the show in
that episode because
we had parts that
would fit his voice.
SETH GREEN: He played
Matt Trakker and Sir
Pentor, by the way.
Very versatile, that
Jon Stewart.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
one more question.
What motivated you guys to do
the "Star Wars" specials?
Like you just had a
bunch of sketches
you just put together?
SETH GREEN: Deep, deep
love of "Star Wars."
TOM ROOT: We went through
this long--
I don't know if you guys
remember, there was a time
when Lucasfilm would just
sue people over and over
and over and over.
SETH GREEN: In all fairness,
that's brand protection.
And Google can understand how
important it is with a global
brand with globally recognize
iconography that's almost more
recognizable than
the crucifix.
You have to preserve
your copyright.
TOM ROOT: That's why people are
always using the Goggle
search engine--
SETH GREEN: RIght.
TOM ROOT: --on TV and movies.
And so for our first few
seasons, we were like, we
can't go near "Star Wars."
they'll just sue us.
And we don't want to
go down that road.
SETH GREEN: But then
we got ballsy.
TOM ROOT: We got a little
full of ourselves.
And we did a "Star
Wars" sketch.
SETH GREEN: First was
the spoiler sketch.
So it was buried inside a much
larger sketch, and it was just
a moment that was "Star Wars."
We had a lot of arguable legal
framework to make a
case for what was
very justifiable parody.
MATT SENREICH: Plus Mark
Hamill did it,
which helped us.
SETH GREEN: But it was right--
it was like in the very--
MATT SENREICH: That
was first season.
SETH GREEN: Yeah, very
first season.
MATT SENREICH: And the second
season, ultimately we ended up
doing our emperor phone
call sketch.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT SENREICH: It was one of
those-- that's really what--
TOM ROOT: Better response
than that baby.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH GREEN: They're less
conflicted emotionally.
MATT SENREICH: I always laugh.
It really was one of those
moments when we aired and it
was right after it aired that
week, where the phone rang.
Caller ID had Lucasfilm on it.
SETH GREEN: And I don't
even think--
I mean, had "Attack of
the Clones" come out?
MATT SENREICH: Um, yes.
"Attack of the Clones" had.
"Revenge of the Sith" hadn't.
No, it did. "Revenge of the
Sith" had come out.
This was 2006, so it was
right after that.
Yeah, but it was one of those
moments where it was that
freeze frame.
SETH GREEN: We freeze.
MATT SENREICH: So I pick up the
phone, and we didn't have
an assistant.
And I was just like, Hi, Matt
Senreich and Seth Green's
office, trying to pretend
like just in case.
And the woman was like, Hi,
my name is Tracy Cannobio.
And I was like--
all right, someone's
fucking with us.
SETH GREEN: Someone clearly
tapped into the phone line and
created this Lucasfilm avatar.
This has to be a joke.
MATT SENREICH: No joke.
That's her name.
And she is in PR up
at Lucasfilm.
And she said that George
has seen the sketch.
He thought it very funny, showed
it at a board meeting,
and invited us up to Lucasfilm
to get a tour.
SETH GREEN: Visit the studio,
go see LucasArts, and go see
all the cool stuff up there.
MATT SENREICH: And we were
there within two weeks.
SETH GREEN: We had a big meeting
with all their people,
and they showed us around,
and we had lunch.
And then they wanted to have a
meeting to talk about what was
the future.
And at that time, Lucasfilm,
far from decision--
I don't even think they'd
done "Clone Wars" yet.
MATT SENREICH: "Clone Wars"
was just starting to--
it hadn't aired yet.
SETH GREEN: It was still
really early.
And Lucasfilm was all effort
towards those films and still
not sure what they
were going to do.
They were trying to
find a strong
presence for the fan relations.
They were starting to
put more emphasis
on all of this content.
And they said, well, maybe
we're going to do a show
that's an amalgam of all the fan
content, and you guys can
build wraparounds or
something for us.
And Matt goes, I've got an idea,
and under the table sort
of subtlety taps me, like
not to say anything.
MATT SENREICH: I kicked him.
SETH GREEN: And I look at him,
and he goes, why don't we do a
half hour of "Robot
Chicken" solely
dedicated to "Star Wars"?
And I just sat there like--
MATT SENREICH: Only one shot.
SETH GREEN: And I watched all
the people in the room go--
huh.
And I shit you not, three weeks
later, we were off and
running on that first special.
MATT SENREICH: It
was really fast.
And then even better was in that
special, George was like,
Oh, I'll do a voice.
SETH GREEN: Well, no, that's
not how it happened.
We wrote a sketch where our nerd
character goes to see a
"Star Wars" Con and
winds up in an
elevator with George Lucas.
And it was just so silly,
and it was just
loving and really funny.
And he has such a strange
reputation because no one
really understands him at all
unless you spend any time with
him, and we just wanted to
show him being silly.
And so we asked everybody in the
company if he would do it.
And they were like,
absolutely not.
Don't even ask.
And they were like,
just keep asking.
And we finally got it in
front of him, and he
was like, all right.
It's like four cues.
It's not a lot of
time commitment.
We would come to him.
And we got him to agree to be in
our show, which was insane.
And even more, we got him to
agree to do a promo about
agreeing to do the show, where
he's sitting on a therapist's
couch being interviewed, and he
says, I can't believe I let
the "Robot Chicken" guys make
a half hour special.
This is the holiday special
all over again!
I hate it!
MATT SENREICH: First take
without the mic.
SETH GREEN: We were like, voice
down just a little bit.
He's like, sorry, getting
into it there.
It was really awesome.
And that was when we knew.
We were like, this guy
is the coolest.
AUDIENCE: So it's obvious
that you guys grew up
playing with toys.
SETH GREEN: What
tipped you off?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
And that even the show now is
the toys doing everything
without you playing with
them as a kid.
So with the great respect that
you have for toys, being at
"ToyFare," et cetera, what's the
chop shop like where you
actually have to get
your favorite
things that you've hunted?
There's so many classics
in the show.
SETH GREEN: Everything is
sacrificed to the cause, yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there a time
that you just can't--
you have to go somewhere else?
Let somebody attack it?
SETH GREEN: You have no idea how
many things have just been
completely destroyed, blown
up, victimized.
TOM ROOT: Even the action
figures that look like we're
just using off-the-shelf action
figures have to be modified.
SETH GREEN: Raped on the inside
and then fused together
to be able to withstand the
horrible pressures.
MATT SENREICH: Our toy wrangler,
Hugh Sterbakov at
the time, had to get
it a classic
vintage Mego Batmobile.
SETH GREEN: First season.
MATT SENREICH: And ended up
buying it from this nice old
woman who said it was part
of a collection.
Please take good care of it.
TOM ROOT: This was my son's.
SETH GREEN: He never
opened it.
Still has the sticker sheet.
MATT SENREICH: And he
tells us the story.
We get it.
And then within 5 seconds the
shop's like, you know we're
going to have to smash
that with a hammer.
SETH GREEN: Because the gag is
it blows up and catches fire.
And I get a call.
I think I was in Hungary
when you called me.
And they're like, we're
going to-- there's no
way to save it, dude.
We're going to hit it with a
heat gun, and then we're going
to smash it with a mallet.
And it's not going to survive.
MATT SENREICH: This thing
cost a fortune.
I mean, you can look it up on
how much this thing cost and
literally it was in
perfect condition.
SETH GREEN: It was pretty.
MATT SENREICH: And destroyed.
SETH GREEN: We got over
it quick, though.
AUDIENCE: There still has to
be a little bit of that in
each one of you.
So what went home?
What even after it was in the
show had to make into or that
display case that you don't ever
want to touch it again.
That it's just your--
SETH GREEN: We've all taken
souvenirs from the show.
TOM ROOT: I've got the Britney
Spears monster in our first
season, actually dating back
to the "Sweet J," right?
SETH GREEN: We rebuilt her
for the first season.
TOM ROOT: It's Britney Spears
grows to Godzilla size, and
each of our hands and feet are
other female pop stars.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM ROOT: And it was built out
of-- you guys ever been on the
Mummy ride at--
is it Universal Studios?
They sell these giant
rubber mummy dolls.
And so I bought one, and
then I donated it.
SETH GREEN: And tore it apart.
Used its basic elements.
TOM ROOT: So that's in
a place of honor
ZEB WELLS: As a newer employee,
I have stolen
nothing from the workplace.
[LAUGHTER]
ZEB WELLS: Next question.
SETH GREEN: Anything that would
ever get reused in the
show is stored somewhere
around the shop.
And anything that gets displayed
is displayed but
would also get put back
in if we needed it.
AUDIENCE: So Humping Robot.
What happened between him and
the Jukebox, and will he ever
find love again?
MATT SENREICH: Well, they did
fly off together in a "Grease"
sketch that we did.
SETH GREEN: The song said we
will always be together.
MATT SENREICH:Yeah.
So I think they're living
happily ever after.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't there
humping afterwards?
MATT SENREICH: Oh, I'm
sure he cheats on her
all the time, yeah.
That's a given.
SETH GREEN: He's not
a one-woman robot.
MATT SENREICH: Yeah.
That's a character that--
that's one of those that I
always write off as who the
fuck knew that one?
SETH GREEN: It was a single
sketch, and it was in the
early days of our
channel flips.
MATT SENREICH: We thought it was
a throwaway silly sketch
that would never, and
it turned into--
TOM ROOT: Well, it's the face.
It's that glazed expression
that he's got.
SETH GREEN: Just
dumbly humping.
But it was in the early episodes
of the first season,
we were still figuring out what
the channel flips were,
and they were more strange
cutaways than they were
standalone jokes.
And so we thought the idea of a
robot just happily humping a
washing machine would be
funny, which it was.
And then we just kept writing
other scenarios for him.
In the last season, they just
invaded the planet.
MATT SENREICH: We had a
"Battleship" sketch where it
was Battle Hump.
SETH GREEN: And it
was up to Officer
Rihanna to save the ocean.
Have you guys not seen
"Battleship"?
TOM ROOT: You guys have got
to see "Battleship." Treat
yourselves to the Blu-ray.
SETH GREEN: More action per
capita than "The Core."
TOM ROOT: True statement.
AUDIENCE: Slightly unrelated,
can you comment on the rumors
that Seth Green will be in
the "Entourage" movie?
MATT SENREICH: In the
"Entourage" movie?
SETH GREEN: I haven't heard
anything about that.
TOM ROOT: Are they really
making that?
MATT SENREICH: Is there a
kickstarter for that?
SETH GREEN: No, I think they're
actually making it.
MATT SENREICH: I hadn't heard.
TOM ROOT: They wrapped it up
so tightly with a bow.
SETH GREEN: I don't know.
It's one of those
things that--
MATT SENREICH: That might happen
on "Robot Chicken" this
season, though.
SETH GREEN: That's one of
those things that's so--
for me as an actor was so
strange because when I first
did it I thought I was doing one
thing, and then over time,
it evolved into something
completely different.
I made "The Italian Job" with
Mark Wahlberg, and then he
started "Entourage"
the year after.
And so he asked me to
come do something.
I wasn't available.
But Kevin Connolly who places
E, he and I have known each
other since we were
seven years old.
We both started in New York
doing commercials.
If you want to see something
very funny, go to YouTube and
look up "Matchbox Car Wash" with
both of our names, and
you will see a hilarious
commercial of seven or
eight-year-old Seth and Kevin
playing with cars.
So we're actually like
old, old friends.
I don't know if anybody saw
this, but I play a hyper super
douche version of myself,
but on "Entourage."
It's hard to explain.
It's very not--
MATT SENREICH: Ultimately
he plays the
asshole version of himself.
And what's crazy is all the
people out in the world are
like, I can't believe he's
really like that, not
realizing that it's
television.
SETH GREEN: There was a moment
where "Entourage" became such
effective propaganda that no one
believed it wasn't reality
television.
And anybody that appeared on it
was immediately assumed to
be exactly that persona, which
I thought was hilarious.
So I kind of leaned into it and
just became like as dick a
version of myself as I could.
Every single scene sunglasses,
texting, like
whatever, brah, whatever.
I thought that was
really funny.
But because I wasn't doing films
as much, because I was
really concentrating on
producing and everything else,
there was an entire generation
gap of kids who didn't know me
from interviews or from
other performances.
They only knew we from
"Entourage." And I noticed
people who were at the
time between 10 and
17 for the next five years were
certain that I was just a
motherfucker.
I had like strangers picking
fights with me in bars.
I was like, what?
And they were like, Turtle
should have knocked you out.
And I was like, you know that's
television, right?
But because everyone had really
become consumed with
"The OC" and whatever,
"Vanderpump "Rules," people
have just become--
MATT SENREICH: Wait,
it wasn't real?
SETH GREEN: No, Vinnie Chase
is a huge movie star.
I loved the "Aquaman" movie.
MATT SENREICH: That
was awesome.
It made $100 million.
SETH GREEN: Cameron
crushed that.
SETH GREEN: So I don't know.
The thing that Doug Ellin, who
is the creator of the show,
said to me was, we love this
one-off gag, and we didn't
want it to become like a
mustache-twirling villain.
I sort of defeats the purpose
of the reality
implication of the show.
And since we'd made it so
theatrical with me and Bow Wow
fighting each other in
the NBC offices.
It just seemed like there's
not too far to go.
AUDIENCE: I think one of my
favorite scenes in "Family
Guy" is when Chris and Peter
are making fun of "Robot
Chicken," like going
back and forth.
SETH GREEN: Me, to.
AUDIENCE: Is there any truth
to how you and MacFarlane
really are with your shows?
Is there a rivalry there?
SETH GREEN: No.
Seth MacFarlane and I,
we love each other.
MATT SENREICH: You know that he
hired Seth to be on "Family
Guy" and still pays him
to do that show.
SETH GREEN: Oh yeah, he's
EPing that show that
I'm doing for Fox.
No, but it's just
a playful thing.
Like MacFarlane, we've been
friends since '98, and the
"Star Wars" things just happened
at the same time.
So we even laughed at one point
at Comic-Con like, holy
shit, dude, I cannot believe two
of the biggest "Star Wars"
fans in the world are getting
to make comedy "Star Wars"
projects at the same time.
And we were in production at the
same time, but ours beat
theirs to air.
And the whole time that we were
developing it, we were on
the phone with the other writers
like, hey, are you
guys doing a Wampa joke?
Hey, are you going to do
this Tatooine joke?
Hey' you're not doing this
Death Star joke?
Just to stay off of each
other's territory.
And in places where we were
crisscrossing, we made sure
our actual jokes were
totally different.
So by the time "Family Guy" was
coming out, it was like
several months after
our show had aired.
So they rewrote this
whole last bit.
And I come in to record
after I've
recorded the entire thing.
And it's this scene of Peter
shit-talking Seth
Green and I was like--
[LAUGHTER]
SETH GREEN: And he was like--
SETH GREEN: And I go,
is this cool?
Is this funny?
He's like, yeah, I think
it's hilarious.
And I was like, I think
it's funny, too.
So that was it.
It was like an inside
ha-ha-ha thing.
But people, I think people
really love drama.
MATT SENREICH: Just to know
history, Seth and Seth used to
live four houses down
from each other.
SETH GREEN: There was
a point where we
lived on the same block.
MATT SENREICH: It's all
in the family, is the
way we look at it.
SETH GREEN: You know we rode
skateboards together in the
neighborhood.
Whatever.
AUDIENCE: Also off topic for
Seth, is there going to be an
"Austin Powers 4"?
SETH GREEN: I have no evidence
to support the yes or no
answer, to tell you the truth.
AUDIENCE: Can you either
confirm or deny?
SETH GREEN: I'm just probably
the last person
to know about that.
I'm probably like number seven
on that call sheet so--
TOM ROOT: Have you
ever asked Mike?
SETH GREEN: The last time I
saw Mike was right before
"Love Guru." He was hosting the
MTV awards, and we did a
bunch of promos for it.
And he was in the greatest
place I'd ever seen him,
literally radiating.
And then that movie
didn't make money.
And people were mad at him.
And he was like, maybe
I'll just sit
this out for a minute.
AUDIENCE: I've got
two, actually.
Will I be able to buy
Apocalypse Pony?
And what happened with
"Star Wars" Detours?
SETH GREEN: I can probably
take that.
Apocalypse Pony is no, but
for a very good reason.
We spent--
MATT SENREICH: We tried.
SETH GREEN: --at least 17 months
credibly pursuing that
with Hasbro and Hasbro
Industries.
And they, to their credit,
were really, really--
they really tried.
MATT SENREICH: They very simply
said, the 10,000 or
20,000 units that it would
ultimately sell for the geeks
of the world like ourselves,
you have to
remember there are--
SETH GREEN: It can't possibly
be justified.
MATT SENREICH: The millions of
people who like the brand of
My Little Pony, think of all
the parents of those
seven-year-old kids who go, what
the hell are you doing to
this pure brand?
SETH GREEN: It was bigger
and simpler than that.
They were like, hey, look,
the four horsemen of the
apocalypse are the harbinger
of the end of the world for
the Biblical community.
So the 10,000 units we could
possibly sell for this
one-time promotional thing at
Comic-Con does not match the--
MATT SENREICH: Business model.
SETH GREEN: --potential 10 years
of protesting we could
have outside our offices
for people that
don't get the joke.
And we were like, I
totally get that.
I totally get that.
And then "Detours," it's even
more simple than that.
When George created the show,
there was no plan to do these
other movies.
And a comedy version of the
"Star Wars" universe isn't the
right first message in these
next three years ramping
up to Episode 7.
So we've produced almost 40
complete episodes of the show.
And at some point, it's going to
be seen, especially in this
world of new media where we have
no idea what the network
model is going to look like in
two years, three years, or
five years.
You look at the Netflix model
of "House of Cards" and how
well that worked, people
buying entire
seasons at a time.
I just expect that "Detours"
lifespan is going to start
after Episode 7, at
the very least.
TOM ROOT: And we've never been
told, look, this is never
coming out.
We've been told this is
going to be delayed.
SETH GREEN: Its strategic
timing.
With a brand that's as globally
as expansive as "Star
Wars." they have to be very
strategic in the way they
release specific information.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, we really want to thank
the "Robot Chicken" guys for
coming to Google LA.
And let's give them all a big
round of applause again.
[APPLAUSE]